more comic-book movie news pretty sure
my channel right now is 50/50 movie
reviews and comic book movie news now
let me touch on this because the reality
of life itself is that I have a
nightstand that looks like this yeah
that's real and that's a lot of Joker
I'm gonna talk about this event
before we get to the Joker casting I'm
gonna talk about the rest of the Suicide
Squad casting which has officially been
announced Suicide Squad if you don't
know it's a DC comic book property where
you have these villains we're kind of
villains but ultimately anti-heroes at
the government Argos anyway which is a
faction of government more or less is
like alright we'll take these guys and
we'll aim them and they can pretty much
do what people can't think Avengers what
anti-heroes Suicide Squad starting off
this list is the one run like okay is
Jai Courtney as boomerang or Captain
Boomerang whatever you want to call
gonna be real with you I know nothing
about the characters self so look at the
actor and actors been in the few movies
sorry was Bruce Willis his son and die
hard 5 if you're one of the two people
who liked that movie he was also in
divergent he's gonna be in Terminator
Genisys with a why I don't want to knock
on the guy I know there's gonna be these
Captain Boomerang fans out there like
how dare you know nothing about Captain
Boomerang I know one thing about
boomerang 1 he was in an episode of
arrow like the episode before last where
he comes out of nowhere throws a
boomerang at nails a guy in the back and
that was the end of the episode that's
what I know but now we have Tom Hardy as
Rick Flagg Rick Flagg as I understand
him again don't know much about this I'm
starting out with the ones that I don't
know that much about so we can really
talk about the ones I do know about Rick
Flagg is kind of like Nick Fury anyone
who's not a fan of the comic books that
don't really know much about him the
average moviegoers gonna watch Suicide
Squad not gonna know much about Rick
Flagg but he's the guy who kind of leads
to charge with the Suicide Squad and
he's played by Tom Hardy which is funny
that Tom Hardy is now in another DC
comic book movie because he was Bane
he's gonna have that cheesy ass moment
maybe Batman runs across him and they
both go now like in the movie maverick
or what it'd be too cheesy not gonna lie
if I'm going into battle I'd want to
follow tom party I'll be like um our
leaders to tank
yeah let's follow that guy but I started
getting excited when I saw the fact that
Will Smith is going to be Deadshot
Deadshot was also an era the basically
you can watch arrows look I know a
little more about the Suicide Squad now
but Will Smith as Deadshot not gonna lie
this is one of the most charismatic
actors in the business do can play
anything I want to see Will Smith in
this movie because it's Will Smith is
really
smart move also marketing wise because
like a Will Smith's in a movie let's
watch it seeing Will Smith as a badass
who never misses how can you not get
excited for that we have Cara
Delevingne I believe that's how you
pronounce your last name dela vine you
know I suck at last names her first name
might have been Cara not Cara in which
case I might have mispronounced the
first name and the last name GA welcome
to my channel however I don't know much
about her also because I don't know much
of what she's been about it took one
look at her and I was like ok looks wise
I could see her as enchantress
enchantress for those of you who don't
know she's she's magical she was the
main antagonist in the first arc of
Justice League dark region part of the
new 52 which is the movie that Guillermo
del Toro wants to do now he reports that
garam el del Toro is Justice League dark
is actually going to be a part of this
whole DC Cinematic Universe they got
going on the fact that in chantry's is
even in this movie gets me excited
because I feel like Justice League dark
is closer than I ever thought it was and
it shows the movies crossing overs like
you have enchantress in the Suicide
Squad movie who else is gonna be in
these movies it makes it feel more like
Marvel ah put your guns away DC fans
it's a compliment then we have the
casting for Harley Quinn and the Joker
and these have been rumors for a little
while now now the rumors have become
fact first of all we have Margot Robbie
as Harley Quinn hey let's face it she's
hot she's a really good actress I saw
that wolf of wallstreet
I think she could be an awesome Harley
Quinn I just got really excited when I
heard Margot Robbie might be Harley
Quinn and now holy SH a she is Harley
Quinn although I thought to myself was
like alright if you have Margot Robbie
as Harley Quinn then you must have the
Joker cast because those two are kind of
a pair although in the new 52 which is
what they looked like these movies are
going off of she's they're not really a
pair kinda had a falling out of stores
but the fact is that Joker is going to
be really important dynamic with Harley
Quinn and now we have the casting for
the Joker which is Jared Leto oh my god
dude I reiterate my nightstand show my
nightstand again that's my nightstand
it's real you know who a good actor is
check this out Jared Leto who I'm
excited to be the Joker Jared Leto
the dude has to look the acting talent
the physique so goes without saying I
think he's gonna be an exciting a really
cool take on the Joker I'm just
interested to see what take they do
I love Heath Ledger's Joker I don't want
everyone to be Heath Ledger fight I
don't want them to put the Joker in a
box I want to see a resurgence of the
comic book Joker you not like the Mark
Hamill Joker from Batman the Animated
Series I'm just saying we live
the world now where you have a magical
enchantress and an alien from Krypton it
was comic book Joker again just want to
see that happen Jared Leto has the
toughest job of everybody Jared Leto has
to make the character of the Joker his
own and also do the character justice
because he does have to fit a certain
criteria I do not envy the guy's job at
all but I have all the faith in the
world for him so Batman V Superman comes
out first and then the next movie is
Suicide Squad here's our I think it's
going to go down somewhere at the end of
Batman V Superman is going to be this
Joker teaser this Joker thing was like
oh it's a joker no kind of like at
the end of Batman Begins turned over the
car and it was a joker and Batman's like
I can't do it so in this movie
something's gonna happen Batman is gonna
be like however Affleck would say yeah I
said I'd look into it do you need me to
say it again he's gonna know the Joker's
in town and then Suicide Squad is gonna
be like oh we're going to take out the
Joker Joker I don't think we'll be part
of the Suicide Squad I actually had
someone tell me that I guess always
gonna be a part of the Suicide Squad if
he is a part of the Suicide Squad it's
simply to mess with Batman he's
typically gonna be there for his own
ends he's going to be using them not the
other way around he's doing it because
he has a bigger plan that's gonna come
to fruition generally speaking I got
really excited for this casting I think
Margot Robbie's gonna be great I'm glad
they have The Enchantress Tom Hardy's
awesome I'm surprised that he's in
another DC comic book property but hey
Mort um party the merrier the dude took
on Captain jean-luc Picard then Batman
now the Joker give the guy the
Congressional Medal of Honor for God's
sakes at this point in fact that Jared
Leto's the Joker just makes me happy
because I get another Joker statue for
my end table that's gonna be Jared Leto
joke so Suicide Squad casting and Jared
Leto cast as the Joker what do you think
about that whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more